good morning Hank it's Monday April 14th
I have three pieces of good news two
pieces of bad news and one piece of
terrible news first some good news
nerdfighters are made of Awesome well I
know that's not really news but I still
get excited about it Hank I just want to
thank the hundreds of nerdfighters on
six continents who have given money to
Shaun in Bangladesh Hank we've raised
more than three thousand dollars as
Shaun told me in an email that's a lot
of money in Bangladesh Hank
nerdfighters with Shaun's help we're
gonna make a lot of people's lives a lot
more awesome if you still want to donate
I put a link in the sidebar finger
moustache bad news I'm not gonna be able
to do a question Tuesday today
nerdfighters thank you for your
thousands of excellent book related
questions I will answer as many of them
as I can in four minutes but
unfortunately for the reasons that will
be outlined in the next bad news and the
terrible news I just don't have time
today you have my solemn vow that I will
do it by the end of the week or else you
can punish me good news Hank I finally
received permission from my publisher to
share the covers of Paper Towns on the
video blog that's right I said covers
plural thank Paper Towns is gonna have
two different covers the book inside
will be identical but you can pick you
know whichever cover you would prefer
Hank there's a lot of reasons why we
chose to have two covers for Paper Towns
but one of the main reasons is that the
girl character in the book is kind of
radically miss apprehended by all the
people around her and we wanted to
capture two of the ways in which she is
radically miss apprehended Hank I really
like both covers and I hope everyone
else does too I'm kind of nervous but
here we go there are the covers of my
new book Paper Towns you can pick the
yellow or you can pick the blue or you
can order online and be surprised
bad news taxes are due tomorrow god I
hate taxes let's move on to some good
news Hank do you know what I'm holding
in mine on video camera holding hand
that's right it's an advanced readers
copy of my new book Paper Towns these
just came out like three days ago well
hello there Margo you're looking very
cute today
so before the real book comes out on
October 16th my publisher prints
advanced reading copies for librarians
and reviewers and stuff they're like
regular books only lower quality and
with typos Marga when I put myself right
next to you like this I feel like I have
a very large head between now and the
publication date October 16th I'm gonna
give away as many advanced readers
copies as I can to nerdfighters and
there's gonna be all kinds of like
fascinating complex games involved in
getting one of these advanced readers
Epis but because i don't really have
time for anything fascinatingly complex
today here's what's gonna happen
everyone who comments on this video at
youtuber at the ning is going to get
their name put in a hat my voice just
Kraft hat and then I'm gonna pick a name
out of that hat and then I'm going to
send this galley to that person and
lastly terrible news
the Eddy's sick poor thing I think
there's nothing that makes me more sad
than seeing a sick Yeti in fact Hank to
help you understand how incredibly sad
it is to see a sick Yeti I'm gonna take
you on a safari okay Hank when looking
for the Yeti we must be very quiet
we must walk quietly she's very sick she
may be asleep is that not the saddest
thing you've ever seen in your life
Hank you're awesome I'll see you on
Wednesday